bonsoir nous sommes le lundi 2 février
nouvelle édition du Journal de la
rédaction et dans l'actualité locale
aujourd'hui la démission d'Henry paayux
une annonce dans la surprise générale de
la démission du poste de maire de
coignère élu depuis 1986 il entend
marquer son opposition la future
intercommunalité coignère doit rejoindre
en janvier 5qu1 en niline culture Lionel
masseta ancien directeur de l'onde
théâtre de velis vill coublé vient de
prendre officiellement la tête de la
scène nationale à Montin Bretonneux il
sera en plateau pour évoquer ses projets
et puis en basket du sport en National 3
victoire samedi de l'équipe de trappe
face à l'Entente le chaînet Versailles
une victoire acquise dans les dernières
minutes maire de coignère depuis 1986
Henry paayux a donc annoncé vendredi
soir sa démission une annonce qui a
surpris son auditoire alors lors de sa
cérémonie de vœux personne ne s'y
attendait lors d'un moment où les élus
en profitent plutôt pour dresser leurs
priorités de l'année à venir Henry paayu
est en ligne avec nous bonsoir Oui
bonsoir vous allez nous expliquer les
raisons de cette annonce mais tout
d'abord sur la décision même à quel
moment vous avez pris la décision de de
quitter votre poste de maire vous êtes
venu encore la semaine dernière en
plateau évoquer les les dossiers de de
votre commune c'était déjà murement
réfléchi oui ah non pas du tout non non
non lorsque j'étais sur votre plateau au
lendemain des élections municipales si
vous vous souvenez vous m'avez demandé
quelles étaient mes intentions pour 2020
h ce à quoi j'avais répondu rapidement
que je vous donnais rendez-vous en 2038
alors qu'est-ce qui a qu'est-ce qui a
motivé à quel moment vous avez pris
cette décision là ça s'est fait et bien
j'ai pris cette décision je dirais allez
on va dire à l'automne dernier et
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui la motive
aujourd'hui c'est la question c'est la
question de l'intercommunalité notamment
ce rattachement à 50 ans neline qui ne
vous a pas plu non la raison est je
dirais extrêmement simple vous savez moi
j'ai été élevé par mes parents et des
gjes j'ai un certain sens de l'éthique
et de la morale et de l'intérêt général
et de la France et là-dessus et bien je
me suis rendu compte que je ne pouvais
plus cautionner ce qui se passait on vit
dans un monde totalement immoral il y a
plus d'éthique il n a plus que l'intérêt
particulier qui prime sur l'intérêt
général et bien ça que voulez-vous c'est
contraire je dirais à ma conception la
vie à la conception de la politique je
suis goliste profondément goiste et donc
à partir de là je me suis rendu compte à
réfléchir que je ne pouvais plus
poursuivre bien évidemment il y a eu
deux déclencheurs dans cette affaire
d'abord le fait que l'autoroute à dou
dans son prongement a été abordonné dans
lerif pour moi c'était une affaire
absolument insupportable relevant de
lobbying je dirais au sein des
ministères dans l'opacité la plus totale
et ensuite alors Seris sur le gâteau et
bien tout ce qui se met en place autour
de l'intercommunalité qui se passe
actuellement dans le casadre du
accélération de on va dire du préfet de
région il defance que je ne comprends
absolument pas il y a bien d'autres
choses bien plus importantes
actuellement àé en France comme le
chômage l'économie autre chose que
d'accélérer le processus sur une affaire
qui de plus et bien ma fois est euh
comment pourrait dire antidémocratique
donc pour vous aujourd'hui entique en
tant que maire en tant que politique
aujourd'hui vous n'avez plus de de de
pouvoir plus de moyen de changer les
choses et vous préférez vous vous
retirer tout simplement je peux pas je
peux pas cautionner si vous voulez des
choses comme ça ce n'est pas possible ce
serait me mentir à moi-même quel accueil
a eu votre votre décision cette cette
démission pour protester en quelques
sens en quelques en quelques mots
comment ça s'est passé comme ça à chaud
je pe pas vous le dire disons que les
300 et quelques personnes qui
m'écoutaient à ma foi ont écouté la
décision que j'ai prise c'est vrai que
nétait dans la confidence que deux ou
trois personnes au niveau des agents
municipaux pour faire une petite
plaquette sur mes 38 ans de service
àanière mais làdessus personne nétait au
courant de décision j'ai prise
donc mais vous avez reçu un soutien de
la part de politique je pense à Gérard
président du Sénat qui était là
notamment oui s était là pierreer
président du général était là allemand
donc bon ils ont eu je dirais des des
propos extrêmement élogieux l'un comme
l'autre concernant euh mais euh ils
n'ont pas je dirais fait de commentaires
particuliers sur la décision que j'ai
prise qui était quand même considéré par
l'ensemble des personnes que j'ai pu
voir après comme étant une décision
extrêmement courageuse et cetera et de
félicitant voilà et vous ne reviendrez
pas on imagine sur cette sur cette
décision comment vont s'organiser les
prochains mois vous allez partir assez
rapidement finalement vers le mois
d'avril ben ma fois je vais j'ai une
équipe qui s'appelle démocratie donc je
je vais la réunir nous allons discuter
donc de la suite parce que je n'ai pas
préparé
ma succession donc nous allons discuter
dans le cadre de l'équipe desbis quand à
la date de départ et bien il y en a deux
où ce sera le 5 mars date de mon
anniversaire et de mes 75 ans ou ce sera
le 14 avril date à laquelle on vote le
budget préitif de l'année parce que je
travaille dessus déjà depuis deux ou TR
mois et donc on verra avec mon équipe si
c'est moi qui fait voter le budget
préitif ou si c'est euh euh mon
successeur voilà et il y a la sortie
aussi dans n autobiographique qu'on va
signaler la force de la conviction àè et
ses combats aux éditions de l'archipel
vous allez vous avez signé cet ouvrage
vous tiendraz plusieurs dédicace on r
donnera bien sûr les les dates sur sur
cette antenne pour pour vous la la
politique c'est terminé une fois que
vous aurez quitté la municipalité pour
conclure oh vous non vous vous savez euh
d'ailleurs c'est sur le 4e de page de de
l'ouvrage dont vous ves parler où la
personne srine rouex qui a largement
participeré à l'édition de ce livre a
écrit que Ben de toute manière tel
bolière je murerai sur scène sur scène
bon manifestement bah pas pas s'est
Tromp mais n'ayez aucune inquiétude pour
moi
moi j'ai tas de choses à faire je
travaille actuellement au service de
l'énergie nucléaire je travaille à la
Fondation Napoléon et au souvenir
napoléonien j'ai un vieux club que j'ai
créé en 1980 qui s'appelle les God fel
de France qui est un club de gastronomie
après tout pourquoi ne pas profiter de
du temps que je vais avoir maintenant
moi je travaillis 20h par jour tous les
jours oui effectivement ou ou vous êtes
on le sait au niveau des réer un club
comme celui-là et puis puis bien
d'autres choses vous savez faire mais je
pas abandon la politique pour merci
Henry pa nous aurons l'occasion merci h
pa nous aurons l'occasion d'en parler
plus longuement vous serez le bienvenu
sur ce plateau pour revenir sur cette
longue carrière politique qui en tout
cas va va s'achever d'une certaine
manière avec ce départ du poste de maire
de coignère merci Henry Paillot d'avoir
été en ligne avec nous merci à vous
toujours en politique à Loucienne
rapidement Pierre François Viard UMP a
étél maire à l'issue du premier tour
avec 52 % des suffrages dimanche une
élection qui s'est déroulée après
l'annulation du précédent scrutin de
mars dernier suite à un recours d'André
vanolbeck udi ce dernier était à la tête
de la ville entre 2001 et 2014 il
n'avait pas digéré la victoire par 15
voix seulement avec son rival cette
fois-ci l'écart est beaucoup plus
prononcé et puis à Rambouillet pour le
scrutin départemental cette fois-ci les
écologistes et le Front de Gauche
annoncent faire campagne commune David
Jutier conseiller municipal de
rambbouillet d'Europe Écologie Les Verts
se présente avec Claire Vigot également
conseiller municipale dans la ville
militante du Front de gauche une
nouvelle déconvenue pour le Parti
socialiste esselé culture avec l'invité
de ce soir Lionel masseta bonsoir vous
êtes le tout nouveau directeur du
Théâtre national de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline vous venez de prendre vos
fonctions aujourd'hui comment c'est
passé cette première journée écoutez la
première journée s'est très bien passée
assez assez dense comme je m'y attendais
mais en fait bon j'ai eu l'occasion de
rencontrer une grande partie de l'équipe
avant cette prise de fonction donc je
savais exactement à quoi m'attendre ce
n'est pas une une totale décou jusqu'à
présent vous étiez le directeur de
Londres c'est le théâtre centre d'art de
véis Villa coublet que vous a apporté
cette expérience pour aujourd'hui
prendre en main le théâtre national la
scène nationale à Montin broton
expérience différente mais
complémentaire différente parce que lond
était un tout nouveau théâtre qui
existait depuis 1 an avant mon arrivée
il y av V eu un premier directeur avec
l'équipe de de Londes on va dire que
j'ai assuré que nous avons assuré tout
le développement du théâtre le
développement et le rayonnement ancrage
local et rayonnement donc ça c'est une
c'est une exp particulière où nous avons
petit à petit développé également toutes
les expressions contemporaines alors que
là le théâtre à 50 ansine était déjà là
donc il faut récupérer le le navire en
cours de route voilà c'està-dire que
j'arrive au cours d'une histoire c'est
un théâtre qui est aussi le symbole de
la
décentralisation culturel c'est un
symbole très fort c'est un symbole au
sein de au sein de la communauté
d'agglomération mais également du
département et au-delà du département
donc je prends cette histoire en cours
je me rends compte aussi de
l'attachement qu'on et les équipes et
les publics à cette scène-là euh
maintenant entre la connaissance que
j'ai du théâtre en tant que spectateur
ou partenaire passé euh et puis en tant
que directeur aujourd'hui il y a un
fossé et maintenant ce fossé j'entends
bien le combler dans les semaines et les
mois à venir votre projet Sion en croit
les échos dans la presse c'est PL r
disciplinaire vous voulez une logique
partenariale avec une ouverture sur le
territoire forcément comme ça c'est fait
jusqu'à présent et rassembler artistes
chercheurs spectateurs il faut continuer
à avoir un lieu comme ça en ébullition
avec différents acteurs oui c'est
important mais on va dire qu'il y a euh
des choses qui vont se poursuivre ou ou
se renforcer et d'autres choses qui vont
être un tout petit peu nouvelles alors
dans les choses qui vont se poursuivre
il y a un travail absolument remarquable
qui a été mené par l'équipe de Jacques
pornan et par Marie Didier qui a assuré
administratrice du lieu qui a assuré
l'intérim et je tiens également à lui
rendre hommage ce soir l'ancien
directeur JAC Pornon ancien directeur de
la scène nationale pendant 10 ans un
travail remarquable qui a été fait
autour de l'art lyrique notamment pas
que un travail de démocratisation
culturelle donc ce travail là autour de
l' lirique va se poursuivre la question
de la pluridisciplinarité qui est au
cœur du projet de cette scène nationale
qui a un cahier des charges la
pluridisciplinarité sera renforcée et
dans les direction de programmation de
la saison prochaine elle est déjà déjà
renforcée ça c'est des choses qui vont
se poursuivre ensuite il va y avoir des
nouveautés en effet euh dans les
nouveautés je citerai je citerai deux
choses la la question des partenariat
vous en parliez elle est essentielle et
pour moi elle est au cœur du projet euh
les partenariats ils vont se renforcer
on parle de partenariat locaux au sein
de la caskie avec des euh des
partenaires naturels que sont les Aes
théâtres que peut être le musée que peut
être le réseau de médiathèque il y a des
partenariats qui peuvent se développer
euh au-delà de la casquie et puis des
partenariats encore au-delà enfin
au-delà de la casquie au-delà du
département et et et dans la régionou
au-delà de la région il est important de
souligner que c'est une scène nationale
donc fortement soutenue par la
Communauté d'Agglomération de 5501 en
Yveline par le département mais
également par l'État avec des missions
très clair à savoir un ancrage local
d'une part mais également une mission de
rayonnement au-delà de la communauté
d'agglomération vous évoquez les
politique la casquille la communauté
d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin
justement qui a un regard sur ce qui se
passe au théâtre et sur votre nomination
aussi d'ailleurs il y a eu des des
consignes particulières des attentes
particulières qui ont été amené par
cette nouvelle équipe de de la
communauté d'agglomération qui a pris en
main le théâtre il y a en même temps que
les responsabilité seulement au moment
des élections au début de l'année
dernière il y a en tout cas un accord
entre les différents partenaires au
projet à savoir la cas qui le ministère
de lariculture et de la communication et
le département pour ils se sont accordés
sur le projet que j'ai que j'ai présenté
et sur notamment les nouveautés dans ce
projet donc l'aspect continuité et les
nouveautés dans les nouveautés c'est la
création alors je vais essayer de pas
être jargonneux mais dans nouveau dans
laboratoire des nouvelles écritures
scéniques depuis des années les
nouvelles technologies mais pas
seulement les nouvelles technologies
apportent une autre façon de faire du
théâtre de faire de la danse de faire du
cirque euh comment est-ce que ces
nouvelles technologies peuvent tentrer
et et peuvent voilà modifier cette façon
et comment est-ce que ça peut modifier
également la perception du du du du
spectateur donc ce laboratoire des
nouvelles écritures scéniques s'appuiera
sur l'association de deux artistes deux
jeunes artistes matthie Roy et Cyril
test qui auront une mission de
programmation qui auront également une
mission de lien entre le théâtre et
l'entité du cluster Paris SACL ça c'est
un point important autre chose également
autre nouveauté c'est que je pense que
ce sera à partir de 2016 2017 la mise en
place de ce que j'ai appelé les
rencontres incité c'est-à-dire que
chaque saison il y aura un temps
événementiel qui pourra durer entre une
semaines et 10 jours autour d'une
thématique et ça permettra des débats
notamment cette thématique cette
thématique permet se rtraiter et c'est
tout l'enjeu du projet serait traité de
différentes manières c'est-à-dire qu'il
y aurait des entrées artistiques il faut
pas oublier que l'art est au cœur de ce
projet c'est une scène national mais il
peut également y avoir des entrées
sociologiques historiques et là aussi
une politique de partenariat qui
s'appuie sur toutes les ressources de ce
territoire en fait ce que j'ai voulu
faire c'est euh progressivement et c'est
ce que l'on verra dans les dans les
années qui viennent progressivement de
façon douce mais continue rapprocher de
plus en plus le théâtre de son
territoire ça permettra de faire rentrer
un nouveau public encore de continuer
cette démocratisation de viser très très
large vous parlerz de l'entrée
historique par exemple alors on pense
peut-être aux chercheurs universit ou
diversifier un peu faire venir un public
jeune aussi oui c'est le cas alors la
politique de diversification des publics
elle est pas nouvelle au théâtre de
Saint-Quentin alors on va là aussi la
renforcer avec toute l'équipe mais
depuis 10 ans et le passage de 30 35000
spectateurs à 60000 spectateurs dans les
salles de théâtre de Saint-Quentin est
aussi un signe qu'il y a un vrai travail
de fond qui est fait depuis plusieurs
années je vous propose à présent
d'écouter notre question du jour le
micro trottoir aujourd'hui qui est
consacré forcément au théâtre de
SaintQuentin en Yveline nous sommes
allés vous demander ce que vous en
pensiez si vous fréquentiez justement ce
théâtre oui la programmation et oui est
intéressante comme je disais c'est varié
euh ça s'adresse à tous les publics y
compris des très jeunes enfants il est
très très bien il est très confortable
on voit bien non non il est très bien
mais bon c'est c'est des spectacles qui
m'intéressent pas j'y suis allé une fois
pour la présentation des programmes et
j'ai été un peu déçu alors c'est VI que
ça fait plus de 3 4 ans que je suis allé
euh non quasiment pas j'y été il y a 2 3
ans en en fait voir un spectacle parce
que je connaissais déjà les personnes
qui le faisaient mais c'est tout et ben
alors parce que la programmation nous
nous attire pas plus que ça et comme
c'est des un peu moderne on a peur de de
s'ennuyer ou de pas trop aimer donc donc
on y va pas bah c'est le programme en
fait c'est pas un des programmes qui me
qui me tente voilà et ben là on a vu la
programmation donc on va voir charer les
coutures et puis et puis petit à petit
on essaiera mais on se dit tout le temps
il faut il faut y aller et donc là voilà
on va commencer faut revoir les
programmes bon allez grosso modo on a
entendu le moderne ça peut faire peur on
préfère plus classique c'est difficile
aussi d'arriver à conjuguer les attentes
de tout le monde mais alors vous parlez
de diversification des public ça tombe
bien j'étais dimanche je suis allé voir
le cirque plus et lorsqu'on parle de
diversification des public il n'y avait
qu'à regarder cette salle de 1000 places
voilà il y a 7 représentations 7000
personnes qui viennent 7000 individus
différents qui viennent et véritablement
toutes les tranches d'âge ensuite sur la
question du contemporain il faut pas
oublier que ce lieu est un lieu de
spectacle vivant par définition c'est
forcément un lieu qui défend aussi les
esthétiques d'aujourd'hui c'est un point
extrêmement important même si c'est
difficile d'approche quelque fois oui
mais c'est un lieu c'est un lieu de
découverte alors pour c'est un lieu de
création c'est un lieu de découverte et
quant à la difficulté des approches le
nombre d'actions qui sont mené pour
démocratiser ces esthétiques nouvelles
est considérable et extrêmement
conséquent donc le travail est le y a un
travail de fond remarquable qui est qui
est effectué et qui se poursuivra une
dernière question qui concerne le prix
des places il y a une discussion presque
un début de de polémique autour de de
prix de place qui était plutôt faible
finalement pour le théâtre national et
le théâtre est aussi là pour dégager
suffisamment d'argent et ne pas être non
plus complètement tributaire des des
pouvoirs publics ça veut dire que la
politique tarifaire va être revue dans
les prochain mois vous faites allusions
au rapport de la Cour des comptes je
pense je rappelle que le prix moyen de
la place au théâtre de 550evine est de
12 € euh il ser il serait très
intéressant de comparer cela au prix
moyen d'une place à Bercy ou ailleurs
cela étant dit 12 € euh oui c'est c'est
12 € c'est ça représente quelque chose
mais l'émission du théâtre de 51 en evel
ne se ne consiste pas uniquement à
accueillir des spectacles c'estàd
l'accueil des spectacles représente
finalement 50 % du travail 50 % du
travail n'est pas forcément visible de
la totalité du public mais il s'agit de
faire un véritable travail de terrain ce
que l'on appelle l'action culturelle
travailler pour permettre à deux
nouveaux publics de pénétrer dans ce
théâtre et ça Bercy et une grande partie
des théâtres privés voir la totalité des
théâtres privés ne le font pas donc ça
veut dire que les prix des places ça va
augmenter ou ça va pas augmenter ça veut
dire que c'est une question mais la
question de l'accessibilité à tous est
une préoccupation de l'équipe du Théâtre
du conseil d'administration du théâtre
mais également de la casquie donc c'est
une réflexion qui est en cours c'est une
réflexion collective il faut que ça
reste accessible mais malgré tout
effectivement vous nous l'avez dit ce
prix est assez faible donc il faut bien
évidemment y réfléchir vu en plus le
contexte économique actuel merci maeta
d'êtevenenue nouveau directeur du
Théâtre national de Saint-Quentin en
iveline je vous laisse partir parce que
je sais que vous avez du travail pour
cette première journée merci à vous on
parle éducation à présent dans ce
journal des tableaux numériques qui font
leur rentrée en grand nombre dans les
écoles de Bois d'Arcy depuis un mois les
classe de 3e cycle du groupe scolaire
vigil Lebrun en sont d'ailleurs équipé
une matinée portes ouvertes était
organisée ce samedi à boisarcy
donc des enfants qui dessinent sur un
tableau numérique dans beaucoup d'écoles
c'est devenu courant ici à boisarcy les
VNI comme on les appelle les vidéos
numériqu interactifs font
progressivement leur apparition depuis
un les classes de CE2 CM1 et CM2 de
cette école pilote en sont équipé les
enseignants ont suivi une première
formation de 3h avant de se lancé ils
étaient d'ailleurs demandeurs j'ai
remarqué dès le moment où j'ai commencé
à travailler sur un sur un TNI que les
élèves étaient beaucoup plus attentifs
étaient beaucoup plus motivés que ça
permettait des échanges entre eux qui
était plus important pour les
enseignants c'est une autre façon de
préparer sa classe puisquon prépare sa
classe euh sur sur l'ordinateur qu'on va
rechercher sur Internet pour proposer
différents supports aux élèves une
révolution non je pense que c'est la
suite de de l'évolution de l'école je
pense que c'est très efficace c'est vrai
que le côté ludique peut permettre de
d'avoir l'attention des enfants leur
concentration ce qui est pas toujours
évident à leur âge donc c'est c'est pas
mal mais après il faut qu'il reste pas
dans la pas dans le trop dans le ludique
manipulation de l'informatique parce que
maintenant c'est devenu que ça
donc après après l'avenir dira mais mais
pour l'instant c'est un petit plus à ce
jour seul le niveau 3e cycle de l'école
viget le brin est équipé à la rentrée de
septembre toutes les classes de CE2 CM1
et CM2 devrai bénéficier de cette
technologie numérique à l'école améliore
les résultats scolaires il y a une plus
grande autonomie des enfants une plus
grande concentration alors bien sûr faut
encadrer tout ça euh il faut pas que ça
devienne un jeu il y a des ressources
pédagogiques sur sur les VNI donc c'est
quelque chose de très sérieux et les
parents sont très contents que ça soit
progressif les années suivantes les
deuxè premers cycles école maternelle
seront à leur tour équipé un VNI cela
coûte 3000 € dont 50 % prise en charge
par le Conseil
Général éducation toujours autre méthode
éducative les écoles alternatives
affirme séduire de plus en plus de
parents méthode Steiner freiner ou
encore Montessori justement à morpa
l'école mon s installé depuis plus de 20
ans vient d'organiser des portes
ouvertes parfois jugé trop permissive la
méthode montessoris qui se veut placer
l'enfant au centre de la pédagogie
semble séduire ces dernières années face
aux hésitations de l'éducation nationale
les parents cherchent une autre approche
où liberté expérience et autodiscipline
sont les mots clés une méthode
développée ici à morpa ce centre
Montessori a ouvert ses portes en
1990 nous présentons des activités aux
enfants que les enfants font autant de
fois et quand ils le veulent dans la
journée il y a une une vie sociale très
intense puisque les enfants fonctionnent
dans le groupe et ils sont pas les uns à
côté des autres mais les uns avec les
autres donc il y a une vie sociale
intense de respect de politesse bien sûr
de de fraternité aussi même pour les
plus grands je vais dire l'échange entre
les enfants est favorisé grâce au
regroupement par tranche d'âge de 20
mois à 3 ans de 3 à 6 ans de 6 à 9 ans
et de 9 à 11 ans je pense que pour
grandir c'est un environnement qui est
serein qui est bienveillant où on est à
l'écoute des enfants où on n'est pas sur
un fonctionnement comme on est dans la
société en général que ce soit à l'école
ou que ce soit dans le milieu
professionnel aussi sur un mode d'échec
de sanction où on cherche à pénaliser et
j'avais trouvé cette approche très
intéressante en théorie et pour ceux qui
craignent le règne de l'enfant roi la
directrice se ve rassurante l'équipe se
définit cependant plus comme des
éducateurs que des enseignants même si
la formation est d'envir enOn 800 he
avant de prendre une classe en main
notre consigne dans notre formation n
dit suivez l'enfant et il vous dira ce
dont il a besoin donc effectivement
c'est pas aussi facile que ça mais on
est on est des guides et il y a des
moments on pourrait ne pas être là du
côté des écoles montessoris on avance le
chiffre de 3500 élèves accueillis à
travers la
France un chiffre
17328 € c'est le montant du chèque remis
par le maire de montinil Bretonneux
président de la communauté
d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline Michel logie à l' FM
l'Association Française contre les
Myopathies la somme a été récoltée lors
du traditionnel Téléton de décembre ce
sont 4000 € de plus que l'an dernier un
mot de sport et la victoire de trappe en
basket en National 3 samedi soir une
victoire au goût particulier car face au
rival yvelinois l'entente le chaîn et
Versailles mais longtemps le sort de la
rencontre aura été incertain Michel el
midoro pour le
résumé le bouillon derby vlinois traap
le chînet a tenu toutes ses promesses
mené est 6261 sur son parquet à 4
minutes 20 de la fin du match les
trapistes ont sur renversé la rencontre
dans les derniers instants pour
l'emporter 81 à 65 après TR quart temp
très compliqués au début je pense qu'on
les a un peu pris de haut euh et par la
suite on a commencé à à se mettre dedans
et ils sont revenus et je veux dire je
pense que comme il dit souvent la somme
de de chaque individu je pense que c'est
ça qui a fait la différence on arrivait
pas à se trouver même si la volonté
était là on arrivrivait vraiment pas à
faire des extra passes et le coach
remédié à ça et par la suite on a réussi
à retrouver nos joueurs et et retrouver
notre jeu en fait notre groupe était
déstabilisé au départ parce que en fait
il nous manquait notre pivot et et et
cette blessure qui est arrivée au
dernier moment les a déstabilisé et ils
sont ils ont effectivement comme le
disait Yan tout à l'heure eu du mal à
rentrer dans le match grâce à cette
victoire traap remonte à la 8e place du
championnat de National 3 avec 22 points
en 15 journées en plus d'un impact
direct sur le classement cette victoire
dans le derby permet de booster le moral
des joueurs de mostaapha elfid c'était
super important super important pour
éviter de de se faire des frayeurs par
la suite donc là si on si on en remporte
encore de trois ça ça ça ça nous aidera
en fait les objectif c'est tout d'abord
de gagner les deux prochains matchs et
d'essayer d'essayer de finir
l'année avec un esprit de groupe
prochain match pour leesc trap 50 ans
Livine samedi prochain à 20h sur le
terrain de malakov victoire impérative
pour assurer le
maintien et dans un instant sur notre
antenne le 78 sport l'essentiel du
weekend il sera forcément question de
hand et de foot US avec le titre mondial
des bleus et le super ball de cette nuit
fin du journal je vous retrouve demain
aux mêmes horaires pour un nouveau point
sur l'actualité locale très bonne
soirée